joining me now is lieutenant colonel
gray green a falklands veteran who is
still serving today uh great to talk to
you what are your memories of that time
and how hard is it on days like today
when you have to relive them
um good morning um
first of all i think it's very important
to
mention that we're here today to
remember the sacrifice of the 255
military personnel uh that were killed
in the falklands war and also to
remember the families
of the fallen
and indeed to remember
those that were wounded both the
physical injuries and the injuries that
are unseen and those that we have to
support
as we go through the next few decades
for myself i was 19 in the falklands war
we'd just completed
a winter deployment in the arctic so we
felt very well trained to operate pretty
much anywhere in the world and we were
on leave and we got the call
to come back to barracks and
then three or four days later we were
sailing south 8 000 miles to the
auckland islands
that must have been quite a thing at
such a tender age were you expecting
seeing active service really at that age
i mean obviously the situation with
northern ireland was ongoing wasn't it
but
um as you say you were yeah
indeed yeah i think um
you you don't expect to go on operations
but you do hope to go on operations and
that's
absolutely the case today with young
young men and women in the armed
services
when we arrived down in the falklands we
deployed
and ashore and to
san carlos
and very soon after that
the unit i was with 4-2 commander and
k-company we were helicoptered forward
to mount kent
the role there was to reinforce 2-2
special air service who were in a
a firefight with argentinian commandos
and that was my first
experience of being
on an active role because we landed the
helicopters
in a fire fight on the foothills about
kent
and that was quite a hairy experience
but i think going forward from there
one of the things that's often forgotten
about
deployments of that kind is is survival
is the harsh conditions and is the
ability of
the british armed forces to go to
environments all over the world and
particularly the falklands and to be
able to survive without kits and
equipment for extended periods of time
and then from that be able to go forward
and
fight the enemy
and i can give you
a couple of examples of that and one
probably in particular that sticks with
me vividly in my own mind
was it was a fighting patrol
on the foothills of mount harriet just
before the main assault
the aim there was for us to go out as a
small team to harass the enemy to expose
uh uh to to expose their their positions
on on the foothills of harriet so that a
wrecking platoon could identify their
their locations
and that was my first experience of
being shot at and and in fact using my
own weapon in anger
and
yeah it's it's brutal it's aggressive
and
it was an experience that i will never
forget the whole mountain erupted in
fire we expended um
our ammunition and then we retreated out
under very accurate artillery fire from
two nine commander regiment which
covered our retreat back to mount kent
and then from there
we moved on to the main assault two or
three days later
and you talked about those who have
injuries that are unseen that the mental
health impacts of of conflicts are
certainly being
uh examined a lot more and people are a
lot more open about them aren't they um
do you have contact with many veterans
who are still really suffering
psychologically for what they went
through then
yeah i i think um
if if you suffer uh
ptsd from operations those operations
can be from the second world war from
the falcons war or indeed those that are
we recognize now in iraq or afghanistan
and these are young
young men and women that have
experienced something traumatic and they
take those experiences with them for the
rest of their lives and they're the
hidden wounds it's really important
for everyone to try and support these
young men and women as they try to
overcome these wounds and certainly from
a royal marine's perspective
we have our royal marines association
and our romney's charity which is there
to support
all of our royal marines in times of
need and especially those at the moment
who have those hidden injuries
you've obviously stayed within the
british armed forces but but when you
look back at those 255 british troops
that died do you think it was worth it
um the falkland islands are british it's
british sovereign territory and
aggressor
um attacked
and occupied the falkland islands
we went down to
recover the falkland islands
and it was a just war in my view